Here's your next challenge app.
At the beginning of the lesson we
created a make your own adventure app
using static segues.
Now we're going to expand on that
app using data driven stories.
Here's the completed version of data
driven make your own adventure.
Here's the tiger story from
the beginning of the lesson.
Just like before we navigate through the
different nodes by clicking on different
prompts.
Most of the story nodes
have two prompts.
But of course the nodes that
ends the story have none.
In a second will look at the code for
the data model that
drives these stories.
Each node in the story has a struct.
That describes the nodes message.
And the prompts to move
on to other story nodes.
Right now, you're looking at
a completed version of the app.
But in the branch for step 5.5.
The table view delegate and
data source methods for
the story node view controller
have been left blank.
When we run this incomplete version,
notice that there are no prompts.
Your task is to modify the story no View
Controller so this table is working.
Let's take a closer look
at the data structure.
The app has four stories stored as
serialized versions of arrays in
dictionaries here in
the supporting files group.
You'll learn more about
how to store arrays and
dictionaries in the iOS
persistence course.
So for
now let's focus on how stored data
is parsed into these model
objects that represent stories.
Here you can see that there's
a class to represent each adventure.
It has a credit's property for
the author's name and
the start node property which
contains the first line of the story.
Initially, these adventures get shown
by the route table view controller.
Here's the table view it governs and
when the user selects a story,
the story node View Controller gets
pushed on to the navigation stack.
Let's take a look at that code.
So here we are in the route
table view controller and
we want to scroll down to
the method didSelectRowAtIndexPath.
So here's what happens when
a user chooses a story.
First you get the adventure object.
Then you grab the first
node in that adventure.
You instantiate the story node View
Controller from the storyboard object.
Then you set the story node that's
going to start that adventure, and
get loaded into the story
node view controller.
And you push the story node view
controller on to the navigation stack.
The story node view controller
shows one story note at a time.
Let's take a look at the struct for
that story node.
Here you can see the message property
that provides the text for the story.
And then there are three different
methods related to the story prompts.
The prompt count which tells you how
many rows that prompt table should have.
The prompt text for a given index and
then the story node objects to
that a given prompt leads to.
You can see that now that we
have an underlying data model,
we don't need all those view controllers
like we had before, we just need this
one story node view controller and
we populate it with different data.
Your challenge is to write the code
that will populate the table of Prompts.
And then perform a push segueway
to the next story node when
a prompt is selected.
If you open up the story
node View Controller, and
you scroll down to the table view
delegate and data source methods,
you'll notice that they're either empty,
or they just have placeholder data.
Your challenge is to fill these
methods in and get the app working.